good afternoon welcome to Sky News at
one there's concern for the safety of
two voluntary workers from Britain who
have gone missing in Ukraine the two men
have been named as Andrew Bagshaw and
Christopher Parry who are in Ukraine to
help with civilian evacuation and the
humanitarian effort in the Donetsk
region Mr Parry has documented his time
there on social media showing what it's
like working near the front line
if you want to go
well Mr Parry spoke to Sky News back in
November about the dangers of evacuating
people in a war zone
kind of take each day as it comes
um sometimes when you see some pretty
terrible things it does stay with you
but in the moment you know you've got a
job
um you've got a you're in a position of
care as soon as you pick these people up
you've got to just get out um get away
from sort of the artillery or the drones
which is kind of constantly going off
around us so
um because of the intensity in the
moment it's fine but it's kind of when
you get back and you start to like
think oh that was kind of close I was
only 100 meters away from us and that's
when you kind of think okay maybe uh
maybe you might like might run out but
it's worth it to save these people I
think